open minds open source open bars
openness is usually seen as a great
virtue but when it comes to open borders
for immigrants and open markets for free
trade leading Democrats and Republicans
sound more like the rednecks on South
Park than the wise statesmen they
purport to be President Obama supports
the trans-pacific partnership which
would lower trade barriers among a dozen
countries but most leading Democrats
including Harry Reid former Maryland
Governor Martin O'Malley and progressive
senator Elizabeth Warren are opposed and
Hillary Clinton who supported the deal
of Secretary of State is now hedging as
she seeks her party's presidential
nomination there are some intellectual
property provisions that are troubling
but that's not what most opponents are
bothered by Democrats have long insisted
on fair trade rather than free trade
which only makes it harder for poorer
countries to compete with the US by
creating rules and regulations that
raise their costs if there's one thing
that virtually all economists agree on
its that reducing trade barriers creates
a richer more prosperous and more
peaceful world former advisors to George
W Bush and Barack Obama have even signed
an open letter urging fast-track
approval of the trans-pacific
partnership for the same reasons that
Adam Smith had it free trade in the
wealth of nations it is he said the
maximum of every prudent master of a
family never to attempt to make it home
but it will cost him more to make than
to buy as it is with families so it is
with nations if mrs. Clinton doesn't
want to listen to Adam Smith or her
former self she might listen to her
husband who signed the North American
Free Trade Agreement over the objections
of his own party back in 1993 we have
made a decision now that will permit us
to create an economic order in the world
that will promote more growth more
equality better preservation of the
environment and a greater possibility of
world peace we are on the verge of a
global economic expansion that is
sparked by the fact that the United
States at this critical moment decided
that we would compete not retreat now if
the Democrats are driven
not by the idea of open markets
Republicans go bananas over the notion
of open borders
virtually all GOP contenders for the
Republican presidential nomination have
called for a timeout or a slowdown on
immigration until they say the border is
fully secured whatever that means and
Motz want only to let in immigrants with
work skills that they say will help the
economy and not take away or lower wages
for native-born workers think about it
Republicans routinely complain that the
government can't deliver the mail or
educate children but they're convinced
that government bureaucrats can
perfectly adjust the mix of foreign
workers in the vast and complicated
American economy yet even economists who
are critical of immigrants with low
skills acknowledge that they don't take
jobs from native workers instead they
head to places where the economy is
booming and employers are desperate for
extra bodies and they stop coming or go
back home when the work dries up
especially if they know they'll be able
to cross borders safely and legally but
Republicans don't have to take it from
libertarians they can just listen to a
guy named Ronald Reagan why don't we
work out some recognition of our mutual
problems make it possible for them to
come here illegally with a work permit
and then while they're working and
earning here they pay taxes here and
when they go on to go back they can go
back and they can cross and open the
border both ways open minds open markets
open borders yeah they're all good
things for reason TV I'm Nicolas Lee